it's not like there could never be a
revolution there but Saudi Arabia has an
enormous amount of money there is an
unemployment problem but most of the key
workers that are brought in and out to
do sort of the lower end jobs are not
Saudis they're van gaal ease they're
Pakistanis they're brought in and they
can be shipped out a lot of Saudis don't
want those jobs refused to take those
jobs now you know when the Saudis decide
that throws 37 billion dollars that
their people is sort of a little
additional stimulus that sounds crass in
the United States it even sounds crass
in New York but you know it's not
crashed in Saudi Arabia that's kind of
part of what the social contract is all
about the Saudi government does have
real legitimacy the House of Saud the
family has real legitimacy among most
Saudis and when minority Shia
populations in the Eastern Province
become restive and say they want the
King to go that actually makes the set
of the Sunnis much more cohesive so the
likelihood that we're going to see the
Saudi regime implode in the near term is
virtually zero and King Abdullah 87
years old what happens if he dies
tomorrow all right well then couldn't it
all blow up no because the family is
very cohesive I mean Crown Prince Sultan
will probably be sidelined because he's
not doing well physically but you'll
bring in Prince naive the Minister of
Interior and there will be a smooth
transition it's kind of like the Vatican
why we won't know what's going on but
then all of a sudden white smoke gray
smoke you got a new person I love
comparing the Saudis to the Vatican
because it's perverse but at the same
time there is a fundamental stability
going on there and and again something
that the media has just really really
you know sort of exaggerated and the
markets have exaggerated because when
anywhere anything happens in Saudi the
markets go nuts